- I'm suicidal.
- [Mark] Really, oh, Jeez.
Let me see that.
- I don't fuck around.
You want to see?
- [Mark] You tried to kill yourself.
- [Patricia] Numerous times, as well.
Poison is what my voices like, it is.
- [Mark] So, Patricia,
tell me where you're from.
- Las Angeles and Philly.
- [Mark] And what's your story?
You have kids?
Do you have a husband?
Are you divorced?
- I have eight kids,
been married three times,
been proposed, by the time
I was 21, seven times.
- [Mark] Seven times?
- Mother fuckers got on their knees.
Then I decided, let me gain weight
so nobody will fucking bother me.
- [Mark] Did it work?
They still bother you, the men love you.
- It's that winning personality.
- [Mark] You're fun, you're fun.
- You know what it's
like when you go to work
and you're like, Oh my God, I
can't, you know, go to work.
That person is there.
- [Mark] That was you?
- I wasn't trying to be that one
but life just gave me it all.
I turned my frown upside
down because I'd been raped.
I've been molested by my brother.
- [Mark] When?
- When I was 24; he came out of prison.
- [Mark] He came out of prison?
- And we were drinking.
I went in to the bathroom and he threw,
when I came out of the bathroom,
he threw me in my mom's
bedroom and fucked me.
And the only thing I could say
was, "Oh, my God, You're my brother."
So, I could not fucking understand,
But then, I thought, fuck men.
I wasn't a prostitute, but what I was was
a family financial advisor
to rectify the household.
See, you got to, better play into that,
because that's what I had to do.
Like a bitch, a mother
fucker would pick me up
and I already had it in my head.
Oh, bitch, you don't want
a pregnant wife at home.
Dudes would be like jacking off
and I was like, bitch, you know,
I don't know and I couldn't handle that.
No, I only lasted like three months.
- [Mark] What would happen
I'm not clear on what
- [Patricia] I was,
being like a prostitute,
like, you know, but I quit it
because I had so much hate
for the men that were
picking me up, you know.
So, I decided I'll be a gangster,
because, if I'm a gangster, I got respect
(Patricia snaps)
And I can pick and choose.
(Patricia huffs)
This pussy is tight and I have eight kids.
One dick in 10 years.
And that was just three days ago.
- [Mark] Good for you.
- I just want to tell everybody,
put your pinky in my pussy.
Just a pinky.
Cause everybody knows, cause I brag.
I have eight kids.
Just a pinky.
Because the ass is a
mother fucking virgin.
I swear to God, I will fuck
you up if you touch that.
I only have one thing.
Yeah, but anyway, my
mother is from New York.
My father is from New York.
- [Mark} Talk about your Childhood.
(Patricia huffs)
- Well, I thought I had a bad childhood
because I was raising my kids,
but reflecting on it,
I had it fucking easy.
But, I'm still a gangster.
You know what I mean?
I'm still alive.
- [Mark] You are, you are.
Are you doing drugs?
Are you using at all?
- I'm drinking.
- [Mark] You're drinking.
(Patricia snaps)
- [Marl] Have you been
up all night drinking?
- Huh?
- [Mark] Have you been up all night?
- Yes.
I can't go, my knees.
I had two knee replacements.
Can I get my drink?
- [Mark] Absolutely.
My mouth is dry, unless you
want me to suck your cock?
- [Mark] Not today.
- [Patricia] Alrighty.
Everybody wants to eat my pussy.
You know what I mean?
(Patricia huffs)
Like why?
I don't understand that.
Because, number one I'm gay.
Mother fucker, you're not getting it,
my bitch can't even eat it right.
I've been with this bitch for 14 years.
She can't even eat it, the
women I had fucking me, like ...
(Patricia sniffs)
My wife has 70 cats.
- [Mark] Hmm.
(Patricia huffs)
- [Mark] Well, Patricia, thank you so much
for talking to me.
You're very interesting and fun.
You're a blast.
- You are a great guy.
- [Mark] I want to party
with you some time.
(Patricia shushes)
- I got to go to New York in three months.
Do you want to go to New York?
- [Mark] With you?
- In three months, like October.
- [Mark] You're something else.
- [Patricia] No, you're something else.
You're a cool cat.
- [Mark] Patricia, I think
we're a good team, you and me.
- [Patricia] I really enjoy your company.
- [Mark] I like to have fun, too.
- Damn, did I have underwear on?
I don't think I did, hon.
- [Mark] I think you did.
- Did I?
Well, they're gone.
(Patricia huffs)